but i remember there was like a world
star video of you and some like asian
chick
where you would having to do interesting
things with smoke a lot of people a lot
of people don't know why i did that like
i'm not proud of that [ __ ] and i always
joke about that shit's gonna come back
and haunt me shout out to sugi
um and there was one before her too
but like
so we're the first ones to ever put a
hash pen in front of the world like no
one's ever seen what everyone uses now
the vape ends i was the first we're the
first crew to ever show that off like my
my guys invented that [ __ ] right
it was before anyone's seen it and um i
was trying to figure out a way to get
equity in the company i'm like yo this
shit's about to be a game this is
[ __ ] 20 90 should be like hit a
[ __ ] hash independent what the [ __ ]
yeah and so um
they didn't really understand the reach
i had and i knew the internet and and
promotion or whatever and it's the world
star era too yeah and so this is when
world star was cracking and so they're
like look if you can get this amazing
around amount of promotion
you know we we consider bringing you as
a partner i'm like all right so i just
thought a stoner girl's gone wild and i
just did it and it hit like millions of
views the same day and i was like is
this good enough and they were so
[ __ ] mad they're like dude what the
[ __ ] would you do that for but everyone
wanted the pen after that
so you know
they're like well you did that once you
can't pull it off again i'm like [ __ ]
i already got an idea and i met suki in
the strip club and
i was like yo you want to be famous and
she was like how i'm like
[ __ ] it'd probably be better if i just
holler at you outside of here and yeah
and i was like look you're gonna smoke
this pen with your ass and she's like
you're [ __ ] nuts
i was like i bet you goes viral and i
bet you [ __ ] goes crazy and she's like
we were i remember never forget we're at
lunch and uh she has to wait so it's
like man man
if i smoke this pen with my ass on
camera does that make me a horse like a
[ __ ] no but it's pretty [ __ ] weird
it's like weird i could deal with
so you know [ __ ] shout out to suki that
[ __ ] went platinum drake dm me because
of that wow drake shot me at dm like oh
you're a wild man you know pull up to me
at the motto video i'm in the bay i'm
like damn that full scene that [ __ ] so
it is what it is man that [ __ ] did what
it did